[Music]
this restaurant with closed doors of
2,725 so it's 293 years that
we've been working like this continuously
without loading the 1,590 cellar everything is
super active it's like entering the past
and the stories
my name is luis javier sánchez álvarez I'm
deputy director of the rest  riot
[Music]
one of the most important things in the
restaurant is the oven the jewel is the
jewel in the crown
the oven has not been turned off for 293 years
I repeat 293 years it has never been turned off it has to
keep warm at night and roast
at night  tomorrow that's why
her dad never has an incredible special aroma
the star dish of the house is the
suckling pig the suckling pig is special the
skin is very crispy with the
holm oak firewood it will be the last touch the skin
sounds for classes o  it is a delicacy and a
delight
the recipes are old from when the
grandparents started the restaurant they have
continued with those recipes from you
feel exactly like when the
grandfather started  They started the kitchen and they taught
the cooks and that followed the tradition
in each of us and
each other
the remaining two today are very
sophisticated dishes all very designed with little
drawings we could not do that
we give a good suckling pig with
some  good potatoes a good plate of
ham that you put with a napkin and
one to enjoy and be happy here for
41 years and cheap I am here as
they say it is a fish in the water it is important to
maintain traditions and foods
that are not lost  the old recipes
imagine that this will close and the
recipes will be lost one's drama
let's hope that everything
continues and that we continue here a lot
[Music]